Hey youtubers, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my Ashara Dayne video.
I'm using Ned Stark as a stand in because
there's no real good media for Ashara Dayne.
She hasn't appeared on the TV Show, there's
no real pictures of her in the books.
And there's not that many pictures from House
Dayne anyway that's okay though we still have
a couple more seasons we know we can see someone
on the show in a flashback maybe I've really
done and Arthur Danye video to talk a little
bit about the history of how staying in general
and that's on I'm not can repeat that this
is mostly going to be about Ashara Dayne in
the later life.
Most people when they talk about Ashara Dayne
talk about how she's kinda looped in with
the mystery behind Jon Snows parentage because
a lot of people think that in the wake of
the tower of joy incident Ned Stark took Dawn
House Dayne's ancestral blade back to their
home of Starfall where Sade and was gave it
to her and then he walked away with baby Jon
Snow in 20 a lot of characters inside the
narrative in the books as well as on the show
think that she is Jon Snow's mother just because
of all those coincidences including Catlin
Stark she suspects that Ashara Dayne news
is the person that never was unfaithful with
that is rewind a little bit just add some
context as to who she is she doesn't sound
like much of a character which is only mentioned
in rumors but she's very beautiful supposedly
coveted by a lot of people including Edward
Stark but also his brother Brandon Stark the
only really counters the George R Martin has
written about her are relative to the Tourney
Harrenhal the really infamous tournament with
the night of the laughing tree as well as
radar turgor and ILyanna Starks encounter
but it's it was a huge tournament most of
the kingdom was there so a lot of other stuff
was going on to in the books bears didn't
sell me talks about her in retrospect he was
one of the people that was infatuated with
her so at the Tourney Harrenhal he hoped to
win the tournament and honor her obviously
didn't go down that way Rhaegar ended up winning
and honor Lyanna start with the crown of blue
roses but bitter bears and sell me say that
five times fast believes that at the Tourney
of Harrenhal someone dishonored her he doesn't
know exactly who it is that he believes that
as a result of that she had a stillborn child
and it led to her committing suicide by jumping
off the battlements of Starfall that you to
remember the Starfall is in the mountains
of eastern door so would almost be like someone
jumping through the moon door in the veil
and that's really sad already and she didn't
commit suicide till after Ned Stark came back
to Starfall but I would that you know coupled
with the idea that her brother had died he
carried on their ancestral blade so when Ned
brought it back it was proof that he was dead
so that probably just compounded any potential
grief if she really did have a stillborn child
that there's no actual evidence for stillborn
child so we just that they included in the
rumors bears and some is a very honorable
person so he's not going to openly lie about
something but if he's really bitter about
something that happened a long time ago in
the past is memory of events might not be
100% of the best fan theory I've seen that
relates to Ashara and Tourney of Harrenhal
being dishonored is Brandon Stark because
he also took the Maidenhead of Lady Dustin
this is where things get a little relationshipy
because if you remember originally Brandon
Stark was betrothed to Catlin she only married
Ned after Brandon was killed by the mad King
along with their father but if you member
Catlin's sister being really crazy about the
love triangle but the three of them had with
little finger it's kind of the same deal with
Lady Dustin and Brandon Stark she just claims
that Brandon never wanted to marry Catlin
and while I Dawn't think the brain is Stark
is quite the man for the Robert Baratheon
and is I think if he was willing to take Lady
Dustin's Maidenhead then he would probably
be willing to have sex with other women to
before they got married Brandon's just said
to be one of the many highborn people that
was infatuated with Ashara Dayne so think
about it this way Ashara Dayne and has a stillborn
child in proximity to when Jon Snow was actually
born Ned Stark maybe find some at the tower
of joy board to his sister Lyanna Stark and
Rhaegar and if he's a really easy way to protect
everyone's honor and hide Jon Snow's true
lineage so that nobody wants to kill himself
like Robert Baratheon and does want to smash
his face in there even if that's true like
even if he's protecting his brothers honor
is bullish Ashara Dayne's honor and his sister's
honor and Jon Snow's life things still and
very very badly for Sade and she still jumps
off the battlements although there is a fan
theory that she potentially went to the east
and took a new persona I was asked admire
people's theories about certain characters
secretly being other characters there is a
theory that Ashara Dayne secretly took the
persona of quaint and went to the East with
Dawn and that Dawn is a light bringer or I
should say to the true version of light bringer
because the unit technically in season two
Amell Sandra sent stances sort on fire and
it starts burning they they call that light
bringer if you choose to take things in a
literal way then yes some of the properties
of Dawn do sound a lot like light bringer
like the dull glow that it gives off the fact
that it was made from a comment that crashed
on planet tows for from a meteor I mean it's
the meteor blade if you want to make some
Final Fantasy jokes but there really is a
lot of evidence to back that up and nothing
I've seen on the show so far supports either
those theories so hopefully that give you
guys some more context for Sade now we Dawn't
know for ever going to see her on the TV show
but if the gonna do a tower of joy flashback
that they might also do some Starfall and
she was there at that time whenever Ned Stark
brought Dawn back there have been any castings
to confirm that's of the show can totally
cut her out let me know in the comments do
you think that Ashara Dayne and had a stillborn
child with Brandon Stark with Ned's older
brother if he was the kind of person that
slept around and they were all in proximity
at the Tourney of Harrenhal and super drunk
just think about the honorable person that
Ned Stark is and what he might have done in
that situation to protect everyone involved
in of Jon Snow Sade and in his brother Brandon
Stark and what barest and sell me remembers
about it even if his memory might be a little
bit twisted he's an honorable person to the
thing is more realistic to believe that Ned
Stark had absolutely nothing to do sexually
with the Sade even though she was a proven
hottie if you're one of those fans that really
likes to write fanfiction there is a lot of
Ashara Dayne and fanfiction out there I'd
I generally try to avoid that kind of stuff
but if you really enjoy it and it's definitely
out there for you to find hopefully Martin
will write some more into the Canon about
her dinner either wins a winner our dream
is spring and just for reference a lot of
people like the most popular belief right
now is that when the winner will be done in
spring of 2016 as being about giveaway winner
to announce congratulations to Christopher
roll you and a copy of a knight of the seven
kingdoms Kindle paperback whenever you want
just be sure to private message me on the
back and my channels and get your contact
info they're supposed to be a new Star Wars
the force awakens trailer on Monday in case
that ends up dropping my Q&A video for this
would just end up posting later in the week
is always a bummer to have to bump videos
but I feel like when it's a Star Wars that
you getting bumped for you can't be too mad
about that but what he is wait for my next
video you can click here to learn all about
Arthur Danye's history in the books and you
can click here to catch up with walking dead
before tonight thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five and I'll see you
guys in a couple hours!